Hello world,
it's Saroj and who's ready to learn some blockchain.
Okay.
For me to be able to write the decentralized applications book two years ago,
I needed to study block chain technology,
hard a f and fast AAF and efficiently AAF since I was simultaneously traveling
through different parts of Asia.
So if I were to start learning blockchain from scratch today,
this is the two month study plan I'd make for myself,
but I'm going to open source it for you wizards since I love it.
This is a two month curriculum dedicated to in order one week of cryptography,
two weeks of Bitcoin,
two weeks of ethereum,
one week of other cryptocurrencies,
and lastly two weeks of decentralized applications.
But before you do anything else,
remember to hit the subscribe button if you haven't yet to stay updated on my
content.
This channel is my life's work.
As you learn this technology,
make sure to follow several blockchain authorities on Twitter to keep up with
the pulse in this space.
And yes,
in Soviet Russia,
blockchain authorities follow you.
Oh,
and for more things to remember before we get started with this curriculum.
First watch videos.
At two x speed and eventually three x speed.
As her brain learns to adapt to faster pacing.
Take notes by hand as you watch for memory retention.
Dedicate at least two hours every single day to uninterrupted learning and yes,
that includes weekends and find a study buddy in our slack channel or someone in
real life.
It will help keep you motivated.
Remember,
this is not a game.
The links for everything will be in the video description.
Before you get into the weeds with crypto currencies,
you have to understand why the word crypto is used in crypto currency crypto
short for cryptography is the art of securing information.
Given some sensitive data,
it asks the question,
how do we prevent a third party,
a k a an adversary from reading that data?
Most people don't realize just how crucial cryptography is for humanity.
Pretty much any kind of money transfer,
authentication flow and mission critical system relies very heavily on
cryptographic techniques to help maintain secrecy and cryptography itself sits
at the intersection of math,
computer science,
and even physics.
But luckily for us it's prerequisites aren't worthy of dedicating weeks of study
too.
We can pick them up in a single well structured cryptography course.
After reading some reviews,
it seems that the intro to cryptography course on Coursera is the best option
here to get started.
It's a seven week course that we're going to complete in a single week.
Don't do any of the graded projects until you finish all of the videos.
Knock them out one by one at the end of this week.
Do the final exam for week seven.
Really put in an effort,
then double check your answers to learn from your mistakes.
Now on two weeks two and three we're going to focus on the blockchain that
started it all bitcoin,
so normally I almost never recommend reading books to learn this kind of thing
since videos are so efficient,
but sometimes there are exceptional books out there like the deep learning book
and where's Waldo.
In this case,
I'm going to recommend my friend Andreas onto Nepalis,
his book mastering bitcoin.
It's open source and available to read on get hub.
Andreas does such a great job of breaking down all the moving parts of the
bitcoin protocol.
His technical writing skills are next level.
There are 12 chapters in this book.
We're gonna read two to three chapters every single day until we finish them
all.
Pacing ourselves included in the book are technical instructions for configuring
and using the bitcoin protocol.
Go ahead and do those via your terminal.
If you get an error at some point,
try to fix it,
but if no luck,
don't get too caught up on it for too long.
Just move on.
After you've completed the book,
go ahead and read the official bitcoin white paper,
specifically an annotated version to make it easier to understand those
concepts.
Then download a bitcoin wallet and buy some Bitcoin.
It can be a really small amounts,
but it's mostly just to feel like you're a part of the network and experienced
the cryptocurrency world firsthand.
For the second week of bitcoin learning.
Take the bitcoin and cryptocurrency technologies course on Coursera.
When you're done with that,
spend the rest of the week building a blockchain that uses the proof of work
consensus algorithm from scratch in your favorite programming language of
choice.
I'd recommend either python or javascript.
There's a great article that explains how to do this,
that I'll add too in the links.
Add as many features to it as you can to get some hands on experience in
blockchain technology.
Now that you've got a handle on Bitcoin,
it's time to go down the second rabbit hole.
Etherium bitcoin removed the need for an intermediary.
When sending someone money over the Internet,
recording all transactions on a public database,
the theory I'm developers realized that they could use the same underlying
blockchain technology to remove the need for an intermediary for running code.
Think of it like a world computer,
a decentralized virtual machine to build uncensorable applications.
On top of,
there's a free really short etherium course on you to me that you should first
check out to help you understand the etherium architecture.
Then you should read the annotated etherium white paper for a better
understanding.
It's much more complex than the bitcoin one,
so really take the time to go through all the details.
It will help you as soon as you start building etherium apps using the solidity
programming language.
Oh and speaking of solidity,
once you finish the course,
you can learn solidity using this crypto zombies game where you learn how smart
contracts work by building them and applying them to this game world is actually
pretty fun.
Lastly,
block geeks.com has a collection of really in depth articles on etherium that
I'd recommend checking out.
Just hit them up one by one once you search for the etherium keyword until you
understand all the parts of the architecture.
So bitcoin and etherium are out of the way,
but what about the other billion cryptocurrencies out there with all of their
unique features and ideas?
Are they worthless?
Yes,
no.
Some of these projects have synthesize some really great ideas,
so we should dedicate this week to learning about some of those best ideas.
I've got a great playlist that goes over the cryptocurrencies.
I find the most interesting right here on youtube that you should definitely
check out.
Remember to go through the associated code and helpful learning links in the
video description for each of them to get a better understanding.
You can spread this bit out to an entire week.
There are rabbit holes you could go down for any of the cryptocurrencies I talk
about from Minero's ring signatures to Cardonas settlements layer.
Let your curiosity guide you this week and for the last part of this curriculum
you're going to wrap it all up by learning about the longer term vision for all
of these technologies.
Decentralized applications.
Start off by reading my book on the topic.
You can find a free version if you Google the name with the word free
afterwards.
Also,
if someone posts a link to the free version in the comments,
I'll pin it so you can check it out.
That'll take you a full week and a lot of the code is deprecated now because of
all the dependencies being updated over time,
but the pseudocode,
the ideas and the theories remain for the very last week.
Build a decentralized application yourself.
Pick an idea,
ride sharing or social networking for example,
and use the fastest method to prototype approach to build something in a single
week and that's it.
I just launched my decentralized applications course at the school of Ai,
but we've currently got a full class,
so sign up there if you want to be notified when the next course opens up.
I hope you found these tips useful.
Please subscribe for more programming videos,
and for now,
I've got to upgrade the web,
so thanks for watching.